There are, for many of us, few people as attractive
as the avoidant; the sort that are permanently
a little mysterious; who don’t speak so
much; around whom one never quite knows where
one is; in whose eyes there is a faraway look,
and perhaps a certain melancholy too; in whose
hearts we intuit a sadness we long to, but
never quite can, touch; people who seem to
promise us intimacy and connection, and yet
who remain – however long we have been with
them – mesmerisingly unreassuring. Unsurprisingly,
it is not so easy to be the lover of an avoidant
person. The tendency, very often, after the
heady early days, is to give into the insecurities
they end up provoking in us: do they really
care? Do they love us back? Why are they never
the ones to call? Beset by such questions,
we may get cross, tearful or stern. We may
accuse them of neglect and selfishness, of
betrayal or egocentricity. These sort of inquisitions
can be counted on to fail. At the first signs
of critique, avoidant people pull up the drawbridge.
They are experts at fleeing the messy consequences
of other people’s desire for them. They
go off to play sport, abscond on a long journey
or discover new responsibilities at the office.
One is left hammering in vain at the gates
of their personal citadel. On a bad day, they
may also get furious back. They will deny
that we have any kind of point at all. They
aren’t trying to deceive us; they genuinely
can’t see the issue. They aren’t – they
assure us with mounting vehemence – distant
and cold, they are simply busy and not into
certain kinds of sentimentality. It is we
– needy, weak, hysterical and over-demanding,
as they put it – who are the problem. We
almost agree.
To survive, we should hold on to the
idea that, despite their robust outward manner,
the avoidant are, above all else, scared.
Their frostiness is the result of fear rather
than indifference – and what they are afraid
of is to let down their guard and then meet
with betrayal and abandonment. Their outward
strength masks a gelatinous interior. There
will, inevitably, be a rather touching backstory
to their advanced subterranean fears. They
were, way back, most likely let down very
badly by someone they depended on a lot when
they were defenceless. In response to a grave
childhood disappointment, they grew an extra
thick skin and plated themselves with armour.
They vowed, in a way they may not now even
recognise, never to trust anyone fully again.
Related image So they are distant and prone
to put up barriers not because they don’t
care, but because being cared for with kindness
generates unfamiliar and daunting feelings
for them. They skillfully undermine their
chances of being close, because they have
no experience of reliable love – and are
drawn to try to spoil it to prove to themselves
that it can’t be real (and that they haven’t,
therefore, missed out on quite so much). We
should avoid getting stuck in cycles of claim
and counter-claim; that they might be too
cold and that we might be too hot. Far better
to address the fears circulating beneath the
surface. Rather than provoking their panic
or denial, we should – as best we can – make
closeness feel safe. We should remember that
we are dealing with someone who finds vulnerability
frightening and therefore not meet their impulse
to flee with punitiveness. But more crucially,
we might along the way, start to ask ourselves
a few key questions. How similar are we to
them, beneath the apparent differences? It
is easy to claim that one has an uncomplicated
desire to be close – so long as one isn’t
put to the test, because one has carefully
picked out a person who has problems being
so. Yet in truth, how simple is closeness
for us really? Might we not be as scared as
they are – but simply have passed our share
of the problem on to them to hold? Shouldn’t
we be suspicious of the way that we managed
to reject other warmer candidates in favour
of this distant figure? Is it really an accident
that we are with them? Or isn’t it in some
way satisfying to us as well, allowing us
to claim that we want intimacy without having
to bear any of its costs? Through
such pointed questions, we stand to realise
that, most probably, the fear of closeness
exists on both sides. It’s just that they
are directly distant and we are so by proxy.
We can break away from caricatures and, as
a couple, own up to our mutual terrors of
dependence. We can start to sympathise with
one another’s techniques for warding off
anxiety and help each other to accept the
common risks of love. That will be the beginning
of true closeness – and bravery – on both
sides.
Did you know we also have an app to help you meet people with whom you can have deeper more meaningful connections?
Follow the link on your screen now to download it.